hello welcome to the bite this week
games I think at a bad rap in the
mainstream press for taking time away
from our real lives but what if games
are actually able to enrich our lives
away from the screen the point season 3
episode 2 can games change who we are
hey what is anti-bias ever
hockey season started up this week it's
basically the most video game a sport
ever but it's not really that popular on
the British Isles it's broadcast at the
wrong time of day and truth be told we
have enough weird sports to keep us busy
however I know how it works I understand
the rules the plays the back and forth
and probably most of the teams but why
well because in 1992 Electronic Arts
released the EA Sports doubleheader for
the Mega Drive in Europe two games in 1
John Madden football and EA hockey
everyone bought it because it was
basically two games for one and suddenly
a generation of Sega gamers in Europe
had a basic grasp of two largely obscure
sports I guess this is to be expected if
you interact with any system long enough
its rules becomes second nature and
because the worlds of games are so rich
with content it's not your systems we
come to understand for instance god of
war gave a generation a loose grasp of
Greek mythology Assassin's Creed allowed
us to explore European history and how
the Bioshock was a crash course in Randy
and objectivism so it is possible to
learn from games but i'm not sure if
they tend to change who we are like
other forms of art when I was growing
off the easiest way to identify yourself
and your peers was with the music you
listen to in the film's you watched
music inspired the clothes you wore
films changed how you thought about
stuff or maybe you've listened to
certain music because you were a certain
way but there was a fundamental
connection between the art and the
person as an adult this happens to I
recently started learning mixed martial
arts after watching UFC for two years
we're bombarded by different aspects of
culture on a day-to-day basis via
television websites radio advertisements
restaurants to even just conversations
we're constantly being molded by our
experience and much of that comes in the
form of entertainment media but games to
me have always been different games are
an escape from our culture like plugging
into the matrix or having a dream the
experiencing games exists in a bubble
and never really changes Who I am as a
person right at least that's what I
thought until Andy behind the camera
dare decided to buy a subaru WRX last
month and I'm pretty sure it's because
you've been mainlining Forza for the
past year
no beer robear telling the story about
how you do something mmm it's like
spinning the narrative in a way right
there's so many factors that led up to
me getting a WRX I've always loved
subers my family's already always had
them I haven't had a car that I've never
really bought my own car well that's
kind of what I wanted to do I got
divorced I'm 30 I want to do something
irresponsible like there's all these
things they like lineup but yeah if it
when it comes down to it probably was
for so that like actually wanted me to
get an interesting car right and since I
love Subarus the double axe is the most
interesting in the lineup and like
that's the car i use and i've been using
them for 25 just I mean obviously the
STI version enforce file is like a
little bit better has only six gears
whereas you know the model I have Lance
five gear so it's like a little bit it's
not like quite that hardcore but it's so
fun to drive it seriously has changed my
outlook on cars whereas before a car was
just like something i got i like handed
down to me from people who didn't want
their car anymore ow especially when we
were filming with that car and i have
joyride it a little bit with it but like
I kind of pushed it hard when we were
filming doesn't look like a camera cuz
you know it's always slower on camera
but like cars so much fun to drive it
should be illegal that probably was I
feel guilty how much fun it is to drive
that car were you intending that stuff
before you started playing like cuz 1400
and then for 25 when you got your xbox
one right it wasn't till I went to turn
10 filling the bunch of stuff they were
like so into it there's this cheesy line
that Brian ekberg use or he's like we
want to turn gamers in the car lovers
and Carla resident gamers which like
makes so much sense when you're looking
at Forza I totally fell in love that
game and then there's a speck just
finally owning a car that's like II
yours like your personality like this
car is definitely
me sign would you have done that if you
hadn't died the game if you hadn't taken
us yeah like I don't know if I would
have been as gung-ho about it I would
have been like do I really need but the
car is just a car just a car I don't
need a car why do I want but now I'm
kind of falling into it with the game
it's pushed me doesn't really you know
like I can have a really good experience
with a car it's so precise like the WX
it's so precise and it feels so good
compared to like my ford taurus which is
what I had before which is like a boat
the four core is not afford 250
things happen maybe she was I wouldn't
ride boy
[Music]
I mean I'm just an impressionable dude I
think though like I wonder if that comes
into it like I'm kind of a sponge and
comes with people like I like yeah I'm
more like to fly on the wall wildflower
type where I think that's the same from
I think that's just like if you like new
experiences you're a type of person yeah
like you are open inherently because you
like new experiences hang out with you I
start talking I start saying things like
you're really HD or I really wanted to
learn drums because of rockland yeah my
I just couldn't landlords but not full
of adventure yeah you know there's a
series i wanted to do for a long time
that's sort of tangential to this was
like how gaming has saved my life yeah
and i think a lot of that is probably
people telling car stories we're like
the reaction time is super good with a
car i played GTA 4 like the day came out
i played a non-stop all night and I was
just going to the store but when I hit
the road look like a new perception is
totally different there was if there was
a construction site and on one sided
road and I was like a light system and
everyone else was stuffed there's like a
train of 20 cars and I'm in the back you
like why not you go around I instantly
just went pocket and I drove into like
down into a constructor which was like a
three foot drop in a fiat punto
through all these like parked JC vs and
then popped off the other side I was
like what the was i doing but you
were just like on autopilot with that
reason I was on autopilot until I went
down happen that I was like oh is this
like the different layout their credits
part of this video where we just talked
about all the times we broke the
law in car and
you must go
just when you come back we talk please
then those that I want no guy like me